welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and spiderman nowhere home
delighted us with how tmi the crossover
chatter among the peter parker's got
covering everything from dead
girlfriends back pain murderous best
friends and which orifices toby's
webbing spews out of one critical
question that was left out was the exact
circumstances of tom holland peter
parker's origin especially because we
got confirmation that oscorp does not
exist in the mcu leading many to now ask
then what spider did bite this peter
parker oh and uh while we're at it i got
a suspicious fight that i would love for
someone to take a look at
jesus uh maybe it was just that sleep
paralysis demon who takes over sometimes
and pushes the mephisto theories it's
him not me anyway when the mcu first
rebooted peter parker as tom holland
they avoided focusing too much on
peter's origin in civil war peter parker
is introduced as a street level hero who
had been appearing on youtube for six
months by the time tony stark met him
and they refer to peter's origin only in
vague terms it's just that when whatever
happened happened it's like my senses
have been dialed to 11.
there's there's way too much input so
they they just kind of help me focus
spider-man homecoming confirmed it was
indeed a spider that bit peter to give
him these powers you got bit by a spider
can you bite me
well it probably would have hurt right
you know whatever even if it did hurt
i'll let it bite
maybe how much did it hurt the spider's
dead ned and then no way home seemed
like it would finally address that bite
ever since i got bit by that spider
i've only had one week
where my life has felt normal
that was when you found out but then as
peter meets his alternate selves they
discuss their alternate histories and
varying web shooting abilities but the
exact nature of the spiders that bit
them never comes up and to further stoke
confusion norman osborne talks about how
the mcu is different from his home
reality saying i had nowhere else to go
someone's living in my house oscorp
doesn't exist also is anyone eating
these donuts because this stolen coat's
got pockets honey godspeed chocolate
clays later on norman compliments
peter's engineering skills saying when
all this is over if you need a job and
you're willing to commute to another
universe a reminder that peter would
need to go to a whole other reality to
work for oscorp and that ozborp does not
exist in the mcu at least not yet and in
the minds of many comic readers oscorp
is the source of the spider bite that
creates spider-man in the ultimate
comics earth 1610 universe both peter
parker and miles morales are bitten by
spiders experimented on by oscorp in
attempt to perfect a super soldier serum
this was the case in the 2012 amazing
spider-man film starring andrew garfield
in which peter's bite came from an
oscorp spider in their experiments to
derive human healing properties from
animals part of dr connor's experiments
which the 2014 follow-up film explored
deeper as part of research by norman
osborne and peter's father implying the
parker dna was why that bite worked on
peter now of course the mcu is set in a
whole alternate reality both from that
film universe and from the comics
technically it's earth 19999 and since
ozcorp is a sony film property the mcu
films disney properties that don't
partner with sony can't really feature
oscorp in their story lines but really
oscorp hasn't always been the source of
peter's spider bite like in the classic
616 continuity the spider that bit peter
was one that was hit with a burst of
gamma radiation by the general tektronix
corporation in the 2002 toby maguire
spider-man it was a genetics lab at
columbia university and in the animated
into the spider-verse film miles morales
spider bite came from the alcamax
corporation therefore the mcu peter
parker's spider bite could have come
from a separate source in oscorp
altogether because the mcu is filled
with weapons developers like shield
hydra the wakandans pymtech hammer tech
aim adrian toombs's crew ultron the ten
rings the red room all those squirrels
and hiding and of course stark
industries and its various disrespected
former employees now how do i keep my
energy up as i'm plowing through these
breakdowns you may wonder well that's
all thanks to emmy emmy is the world's
first low low-carb high protein 100
plant-based instant ramen each serving
of imme has 21 grams of protein 19 grams
of fiber and only 6 grams of net carbs
it's non-gmo and is 35 percent lower in
sodium than traditional brands the
flavor i've been enjoying this
it's all good with only 6 grams of net
carbs per serving emmy makes it easy to
reach your healthy goals the 21 grams of
plant-based dairy-free protein helps you
stay full longer and the 18 grams of
fiber and 35 less sodium than other
instant ramen brands keeps you from
getting that weird thirst after you just
downed a bowl of liquid emmy is super
easy to prepare in the microwave or
stovetop and you can have a bowl ready
in seven minutes they've got some great
flavors to pick from black garlic
chicken but also spicy beef tom yum
shrimp stock your pantry with some
delicious healthy emmy ramen by clicking
the link below and using code new
rockstars at checkout or go to
emmyeats.com
new rockstars for five dollars off your
order that's emmyeats.com
new rockstars or click the link below
and use code new rockstars for five
dollars off a variety pack today in
civil war peter said that he had had his
powers for six months and since civil
war was set in may 2016 this means the
bite occurred sometime in late 2015 and
that period in history was shortly after
tony stark left manhattan and moved all
the avengers operations to his upstate
new york compound however much of his
technology was left behind in that
midtown tower based on happy hogan being
assigned to move the rest of tony's
stuff out of the tower in spider-man
homecoming that included some dangerous
like several arc reactors iron man
mark 42 armor a new prototype captain
america shield thor's magic belt so we
got a pretty big window in which some of
the world's most advanced technology in
research was left behind largely
unattended in the middle of new york
city and remember this was also the
period in history when tony stark
heavily invested in all kinds of odd
projects like the raft prison facility
he built for the government his barf
technology that he got from quentin beck
the various mit student projects that he
funded and curiously a fresh spider-man
suit that he had ready to go within days
of supposedly meeting peter parker and
queens for the first time time and time
again the mcu spider-man film set peter
parker in a world impacted in every
possible way by tony stark adrian toombs
quentin beck both stark created villains
the suits the blip even peter's cures
for the villains in no way home came
from the stark fabricator so coming back
to that moment in civil war when tony
said that he knew of a kid in queens do
we really think he was just stalking
peter's heroics on youtube or as he
sneakily hinted throughout spider-man
homecoming that he was actually
monitoring peter's every move even peter
thought that happy and tony totally
ignored stay close to the ground build
up your game helping the little people
like that lady that bunch of the churro
uh i'm at band practice that's odd happy
told me you quit banned six weeks ago
and since kevin feige confirmed that the
kid that tony saved at the stark expo in
iron man 2 was a young peter parker is
it really that big of a reach to assume
that some prior connection could have
existed between peter and stark please
remember bruce banner said that he cured
himself by spending 18 months in the
gamma lab a gamma lab that seems to show
up in she-hulk and presumably some
version of this lab must have existed in
avengers tower considering bruce banner
was hanging up his laundry there so i
think sometime during the avengers
transition upstate in late 2015 a young
peter parker snooped around the
abandoned lab of his icons got bitten by
a spider that was irradiated the same
way the spider was originally irradiated
in the 60s comics and tony stark found
out about this and began tracking this
kid as a potential recruit and he
ordered happy hogan to clear the rest of
that stuff out of the tower so it would
never happen again so how did the mcu
peter parker get bitten by spider
without oz corp easy classic game of
radiation from the same source of
everything else in the mcu stark
industries the cause of and solution to
all life's problems you can support new
rockstars by checking out our merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter at ea boss
follow new rockstars and subscribe to
the rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you